now to another big story this morning US
allies are calling North Korea's latest
missile tests a significant provocation
the missile flew directly over Japan
yesterday and splashed down in the
Pacific Ocean it was the first time this
has happened since 2009 been Tracie's in
Tokyo where japan's Prime Minister spoke
with President Trump shortly after that
launch Ben good morning good morning so
millions of people here in Japan woke up
to a message on their cell phones that
said missile passing please take cover
even some of the famed bullet trains in
this country came to a screeching halt
when North Korea launched this missile
with no warning sirens blared through
the streets in northern Japan early
Tuesday morning telling people to get
inside and take cover
the Japanese woke up to warnings that
North Korea had launched a ballistic
missile that flew directly over the
island the missile was launched near the
North Korean capital possibly from a
mobile launch pad near the Pyongyang
Airport it flew more than 1,600 miles
crossing over the Japanese island of
Hokkaido
before splashing down in the Pacific
Ocean Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe
a called the launch an unprecedented and
grave threat South Korea another US ally
responded by conducting live fire drills
with f-15 fighter jets releasing this
footage of its own missile test
conducted last week North Korea's
missile launch is the latest show of
force from leader Kim Jong moon the
country successfully tested two
intercontinental ballistic missiles last
month capable of reaching
United States that led to a war of words
with President Trump who last week
suggested his tough talk on North Korea
was working Kim jong-un I respect the
fact that I believe he is starting to
respect us I respect that fact
now since Kim jong-un became the leader
of North Korea he has launched more than
80 missiles but never a single one over
Japan so this was literally a warning
shot of some kind
although the message is not entirely
clear Margaret
significant and the White House has not
yet commented Ben Tracy in Tokyo thank
you